et avec nous pour ce grand débat en
partenariat avec la sacem jean noël
tronc bienvenue vous êtes directeur
général de la sacem vous avez publié en
2018 et si on recommençait par la
culture plaidoyer pour la souveraineté
européenne
julien bargeton bienvenue vous êtes
sénateur r&d pays de paris re des pays
c'est donc en marche au sénat vice
président de la commission de la culture
de l'éducation et de la communication
blick bassy est également avec nous bien
venu vous êtes chanteur compositeur
guitariste percussionniste vous êtes
originaire du cameroun votre dernier
album c'est 1958 sorti sur le label no
format tôt ou tard et vous avez reçu le
grand prix sacem des musiques du monde
c'était donc l'année dernière en 2019
romain goupil est également avec nous
bien venu vous êtes acteur réalisateur
scénariste et engagé on le sait auprès
d' emmanuel macron merci à tous les
quatre d'être avec nous ce soir
pour cette émission spéciale jean noël
tronc qu'est ce qui a motivé
l'organisation de cette journée d'abord
la situation j'en veux dire elle est
grave à ce point expliquez-nous ce qui
se passe oui aller catastrophique enfin
il faut le dire pour beaucoup de
secteurs mais notamment la filière
musicale 1,2 de mémoire ces deux cent
quarante mille emplois en france et une
estimation faite par une étude du
cabinet lillois et montre qu'on risque
de perdre à peu près la moitié des
revenus de cette filière musicale dans
certains secteurs comme les spectacles
vivants c'est 80 % de perte de revenus
et on a voulu alerter sur le maillon
faible que sont les auteurs et les
compositeurs de musique et puis leurs
partenaires les éditeurs de musique qui
sont en général peu connue alors qu'ils
sont à l'origine de toute la création
pour la musique comme on devait faire
nos grands prix sacem comme chaque année
ce soir et que pour des raisons
d'économie on a décidé avant l'été d
annuler purement et simplement
c'est une journée de solidarité à la
place des grands prix sacem et je veux
remercier du fond du coeur public sénat
de ceux de ce soutien qui va permettre
de faire un peu entendre la voix ce
maillon faible qui est aussi le maillon
fort on l'espère évidemment blick bassy
merci d'être avec nous vous êtes un
artiste qui monte qui monte depuis
plusieurs années maintenant est-ce que
vous avez le sentiment que cette crise
est en train de vous stoppé en plein vol
absolument j'étais en fait j'ai un album
qui est sorti en début du dix neuf et
donc la tournée été lancé pour 2020 2021
est en fait la crise venue stopper le
bilan de cette tournée entre le volant
et aujourd'hui ministre vraiment une
partie que je sais que ce n'est pas
terminé et que l'année l'année prochaine
sur tout mais on le réduit qu'en tant
qu'auteur compositeur seront
complètement réduit sachant que non en
tant qu'artiste notre vie nous
proviennent de des droits d'auteur et
donc oui on s'est fait très très train
de passer des moments très très
difficiles et nous ne savons pas encore
ce qu'il se passera l'année prochaine et
concrètement de quoi est fait votre
quotidien de puisqu'au vide c'est qu'il
ya plus de concerts est ce que vous
faites quand même des concerts virtuels
on voit que certains artistes ont saisi
l'occasion des réseaux sociaux pour se
faire connaître ou en tout cas être
suivie par par leurs fans c'est ce que
vous faites aussi moi au départ compte
quand le premier continent est arrivé on
était tous animés d'une envie de jouer
un peu parce que j'étais la première
fois depuis très très longtemps depuis
je fais la musique je me retrouvais
coincé chez moi sans pouvoir aller faire
mon travail dans lé là entre du public
et donc les premiers jours j'ai eu si
peu de jouer un peu sur internet
finalement je me suis arrêté parce que
je me suis dit tout de suite que il
fallait pas tes habitudes
les méchants les internautes tout
simplement à penser que la musique est
un travail et est un produit qu ensemble
de manière gratuite et mais surtout de
se dire que moi qui suis le bleu nous
les auteurs compositeurs qui sont les
plus impactées c'est aussi un nom de
pouvoir contribuer tout simplement à
aider les gens à passer en confinement
beaucoup moins difficile donc il y avait
une espèce de dilemme je me disais ils
surent projet pas trop envie de jouer
pour habituer les gens à consommer
gratuitement mais en même temps notre
rôle étant aussi tout simplement de
pouvoir aider des familles qui se
retrouvaient dans les conditions très
très difficile de pouvoir passer cette
crise chez eux avec parfois des familles
très nombreuses qui on sait bien les
dégâts qui a eu dans certaines familles
donc c'était suite est très très
difficile mais on continue à composer
ont continué à travailler on voit bien
que pour beaucoup le compositeur de
musique de film également c'est très
compliqué parce que notre image à
l'arrêt aussi et on espère tout
simplement que l'année prochaine des
choses on peut peut-être un petit à
petit s'unissent pour repartir et donc
on commence à préparer l'après qu'on
vide sans savoir si ces jours prochains
après conduite est évidemment ce projet
être un petit peu sur l'avenir tout à
l'heure julien bargeton c'est vrai que
quand on parle de la culture en crise et
notamment de la musique en crise
beaucoup de gens disent oh ça va il s'en
mettre plein les poches tout au long de
l'année leurs concerts sont leurs places
de concerts soit hors de prix les albums
peuvent être cher enfin tout ça est en
fait on se rend compte quand même que
c'est un univers qui est vraiment crise
gravement crise et il n'y a pas que les
artistes en haut de la fiche qui peuvent
effectivement gagné très bien leur vie
mais qui aussi peuvent être dans des
situations très précaires
la culture a été gravement atteinte par
cette crise mais c'est vrai qu'il ya
différents secteurs culturels les
intermittents du spectacle par exemple
ont une année blanche les établissements
publics les subventions sont reconduites
il ya des soutiens de l'état qui est
très fort donc les jeux vidéos et tout
ce qui est numérique s'est bien porté
pendant la crise mais c'est vrai qu'il
ya des secteurs qui sont très touchées
notamment tous les auteurs compositeurs
également les plasticiens par exemple il
faut aussi penser aux plasticiens pour
qui c'est très doux
s'il met également bien sûr le cinéma
donc on voit bien que l'impact est
différent d'un certain côté
paradoxalement cette crise a quand même
révélé la la trêve le très fort
attachement des français la culture on
l'a vu avec les librairies on le voit
avec la musique il y a quand même un
attachement qui est apparu assez rassuré
puis pour répondre à votre question est
si oui mais pour répondre à votre
question on s'est rendu compte que
pardonner mon expression s'agit pas
seulement de saltimbanco stamm et que
derrière les beaucoup d'emplois et que
certains secteurs économiques et tout
d'un coup on ça a révélé aussi l'enjeu
économique derrière ce qui est bien sûr
la culture c'est à dire l'art ce que ça
nous apporte ce que le bouleversement le
plaisir enfin le fait d'aimer l'art et
la musique et la culture mais aussi en
france il ya des emplois derrière il ya
beaucoup de gens qui travaillent et ça
ça a été très bien vu donc l'engagement
du du mystère la culture est très fort
je voudrais saluer aussi le centre
national de la musique qui a été créée
cette année et il se trouve que le
baptême du feu du centre national de la
musique a été très dur puisque il a été
inauguré avec une crise majeure
il a joué un rôle très important il a
mis en place des fonds et le plan de
relance lui apporte plusieurs centaines
de millions d'euros qui sont bienvenus
romain goupil comment voyez cela vous
qui connaissez peut-être davantage le
milieu du cinéma celui d'aider des
acteurs et aussi des intermittents du
spectacle qui sont dans cet univers est
ce que la situation est tout aussi
catastrophique que nous le dit jean noël
tronc pour ce qui est de la musique
c'est pour tout le monde mais il se
trouve qu'il est de 7 heures il ya le
cinéma les choses existantes la musique
l'opéra qu'il harmonique de paris où le
gouvernement va faire des efforts
maximums pour éviter un effondrement
mais deux choses qui existent mais la
culture c'est tout ce qui est beau
sionnel
intellectuel que kiki en ce moment va
prendre le risque d'éditer un romancier
inconnu d'aider un cinéaste en herbe de
donner une chance à un comédien et pour
la musique c'est épouvantable c'est à
dire vous avez besoin d'un public vous
avez besoin d'un psy vous débutez mais
qui va faire confiance en ce moment
animaux pour nous qui grâce à la sacem
grâce aux syndicats
en effet des films on arrive et encore
c'est extrêmement compliqué pour les
auteurs et les autres east les
scénaristes
comment vous voulez vous projetez alors
que tous les tournages sont condamnés au
condamné
s'il ya un cas qu'ovide alors que les
acteurs ne peuvent pas donner date pour
faire un tournage alors que les salles
sont fermées donc j'ai filmé ne peuvent
pas se rentabiliser c'est une
catastrophe mais surtout la catastrophe
c'est ont tous ceux qui aspirent qui ont
envie qui rêve de ça c'est à dire pour
tous les jeunes pour tous les maux pour
les ceux qui font de la musique qui en
vivent et qui arrive à en vivre mais
ceux qui espéraient
c'est un désespoir pour porter toute une
série de secteurs et je vous parle pas
de l'économie grise qui est quelque
chose habituelle dans nos milieux qui
sont autour des festivals les hôtesses
les chauffeurs les tout ce que ça
implique les voilà de nuit tout ça
disparaît a disparu donc c'est
extrêmement compliqué évidemment très
angoissant et évidemment tous les
secteurs touchés par cette crise
demandent plus des aides de l'état le
secteur de la culture ne fait pas
exception on a vu dans le sujet de
baptiste d'epinay tout ce qu'ils avaient
quand même été débloqués pour certains
c'est encore insuffisant en préparant
cette émission s'est rappelé cette
interview sur ce même plateau de didier
fusiller
président du parc de la villette on
était alors en juillet dont juste après
la première vague et après les critiques
qui avaient été émises contre franck
riester prédécesseur de roselyne
bachelot
sa réponse nous avait interpellés
écouter mme allemagne par exemple tous
les théâtres ont fermé et normalement il
n'ouvre pas avant la fin décembre
il n'y a aucune mesure comme de ce que
nous connaissons nous être les
intermittents le président de la
république annoncé une année blanche
ça n'existe nulle part en europe même
dans le monde une protection pareil
fermer tous les cinémas enfin des
chaudes tous les festivals qui saute
alors que la france est quand même une
grande terre de festivals c'est pas que
avignon c'est tous les grands festivals
de danse montpellier qui savent tout le
monde a dû fermer voyez ce qui se passe
en espagne je vais même pas dire à
shanghai ou en espagne au portugal là
c'est rien du tout les artistes
réservant pour la culture c'est pas zéro
c'est des demandes d'indemnisation cas
par cas étudiés sincèrement je pense que
il faut il faut prendre la mesure
on peut pas annoncer aux landais
lendemain du confinement
on va vous demain il faut prendre la
mesure de choc et je reprécise donc là
on était après la première vague et
disait en gros on a quand même de la
chance d'être en france parce que
l'exécutif a fait beaucoup pour la
culture que diriez-vous aujourd'hui jean
d'altran ce que c'est exact que la
france fait partie de ces pays on a mis
de l'argent sur la table pour la culture
que c'était l'été dernier et donc moi je
réponds deux choses ce qui nous
interpelle sur ce que nous demandons la
première c'est que concernant les
auteurs compositeurs et éditeurs de
musique comme ça a été parfaitement dit
avant moi par les intervenants sur ce
plateau
les auteurs compositeurs ont cette
particularité qu'il ne sont pas salariés
que rares sont ceux d'entre eux qui ont
l'intermittent du spectacle souvent
n'étant pas et après ils n'ont pas de
cash et des éditeurs de musique
c'est la seule des branches des
entreprises de la musique qui n'a même
pas accès au crédit d'impôt alors que ça
fait 15 ans qu'on en parle
bon les concernant et je voudrais vous
remercier ici je les ai marre jetons
ainsi que les sénateurs et sénatrices
laure darcos sylvie robert david
assouline et et roger karouchi parce
qu'on a une forme d'union sacrée à
l'assemblée nationale et au sénat
saint geours la fin d'une injustice et
que ce crédit d'impôt puisse être
poussés il faut maintenant que le
gouvernement dise oui en ce qui concerne
les auteurs compositeurs il faut des
compensations pour des pertes même
limité mais alors en ce qui concerne ce
que les uns et les autres on peut faire
deux messages d'abord les radios
elle-même et les médias qui sont les
seuls à ne pas avoir fermé le plus début
de cette crise qui diffuse plus plus
vous diffuserez la production française
plus nous la sacem canton versera les
droits d'auteur on pourra les versées à
la filière créatif française parce que
sinon on va perdre une génération on
peut pas diffuser une musique mais
là-dessus donne l'exemple j'espère que
d'autres chaînes de télévision vous
imiteront on a lancé
sybille veille et moi au mois d'avril
cette idée de hashtag scène française il
ya 250 radio qui nous ont rejoints mais
il faut les actes concrets il ya une
dernière chose et je reviens ce que
disait du des fusillés c'est que si on
rate les festivals de juillet 2021 alors
là la casse sera irréversible
c'est en janvier février ou plus tard
qu'il faut que le gouvernement puisse
dire voilà ce qu'est un calendrier de
déconfinement complet avec tous les
risques sanitaires que nous connaissons
mais si on ne dit pas au festival
si on ne dit pas aux artistes qui vont
faire des tournées quelques mois avant
ce qui va être possible ça ça sera une
année blanche en 2021 aussi
contrairement à un film qu'on peut
projeter du jour au lendemain dans une
salle de cinéma un spectacle il faut
parfois des mois pour le prévoir une
tournée c'est des semaines de
préparation alors l'exécutif en fait il
a c'est pas pour tout le monde pas pour
certains sénateurs mais je vais vous
donner la parole j'ai un bar j'attends
je vous le promets mi-novembre dans
l'hémicycle ici au sénat le sénateur
écologiste thomas d'hossus alerté le
gouvernement sur un cas précis celui de
la musique électronique complètement
oublié selon lui il proposait alors un
fonds soutien de 20 millions d'euros
il a eu droit à une fin de non-recevoir
d'olivier du soft écouter aujourd'hui se
joue la survie de milliers d'artistes et
l'écosystème qui l'entourent et un
secteur qui pèse plus de 4400 millions
d'euros contenus
compte tenu du contexte ils n'auront pas
de perspective avant très longtemps ils
passent souvent à travers les mailles
des différents soutiens qui pourrait que
pourrait leur apporter le ministère la
culture ou autre
c'est pourquoi par la création de ce
fonds soutien spécifique pour les
musiques actuelles électronique nous
souhaitons apporter à la fois la
reconnaissance de leur place dans le
patrimoine culturel français
ainsi que des moyens pour traverser la
crise actuelle merci nous avons déjà
dégagé plus de plusieurs centaines de
millions d'euros pour le secteur de la
culture et ce plfr l'occasion de dégager
100 millions d'euros supplémentaires
pour les industries culturelles
par ailleurs la création les artistes
fragilisé font l'objet de dispositions
spécifiques dans le cadre du plan de
relance madame la ministre de la culture
a eu aura l'occasion de présenter devant
votre commission j'en suis convaincu
donc nous ne pensons pas opportun ce
stade de créer des programmes
supplémentaires
julien bargeton ans la question sera
très directe tout at il été fait pour
aider le secteur de la culture face à
cette crise et pour les enjeux à venir
dont on vient de parler jean noël tronc
en france le maximum a été fait je le
crois et je pense la musique
électronique en effet qu'il souffre
beaucoup parce que c'est très lié au
milieu de la nuit doit pouvoir
bénéficier notamment de tous les fonds
mis en place par le centre national de
la musique qui à près de 400 millions
d'euros dans le dans le dans le plan de
relance donc c'est quand même un effort
important en france il faut quand même
voir une chose c'est que on a soutenu
des des lieux on a soutenu des des
artistes ailleurs il ya quand même des
or qu'est-ce qui licencient il ya des
opérations totalement annulé leur saison
et qui licencient il y a énormément de
pertes d'emplois plus qu'en france et
ailleurs en europe ou dans le monde
donc en france on est comme le rat un
des rares pays à avoir le système
intermittents du spectacle est à voir ça
coûte un peu plus d'un milliard d'euros
l'année blanche
alors je reconnais bien sûr que tout
n'est pas rose c'est ce que disait
romain goupil est très juste ce qui nous
attriste le plus c'est le fait que des
rencontres n'ont pas lieu on peut se
dire que quelqu'un qui est une idée de
livre une idée de chanson une idée de
spectacle bon il essaie on fait
confiance à la créativité humaine et
donc peut-être qu'il le fera dans un an
dans deux ans mais n'empêche que les
festivals qui n'ont pas eu lieu
c'est des rencontres de production qui
n'ont pas eu lieu et qui sont très
difficiles à rattraper mais ça et puis
viennent par curiosité et j'ai mal tig
parce que parce que là
la culture c'est aussi des rencontres
c'est aussi des chances et quand il ya
une perte de chance ça c'est ce qu'à 13
ans mais en même temps on se dit que on
espère tous avec les vaccins qui est une
relance que ça reparte et que quelqu'un
qui a un projet bien pour à un moment le
mener à bien que ce soit un livre une
une édition musicale et c'est donc tout
n'est pas parfait c'est pas du tout ce
que je veux dire
mais mais l'effort en france il est
quand même massif et notamment via le
centre national de la musique pour le
secteur de la musique
et puis aussi via les crédits d'impôt
j'espère qu'on pourra aller plus loin en
effet sur les crédits d'impôts mais
c'est 170 millions le cnm
oui à 2021 soyons clairs il y aura
peut-être une programmation
pluriannuelle jusqu'à 400 c'est ça sur
deux ans pardon cerf-volant sites est
monsieur le sénateur mais demain matin
doit être présenté à la filière musicale
le projet de budget pour 2021 ses 170
millions d'euros en tout et pour tout
pour le sensationnel de la musique
moi je demande en tant que patron la
sacem qui au moins une trentaine de
millions d'euros
sur ces 70 c'est à dire à peine 15% pour
les métiers les auteurs compositeurs et
éditeurs de musique
ça me paraît pas disproportionnée
j'espère que nous allons être entendu
mais pour des lieux comme les clubs où
les discothèques pour lesquels pour
l'instant il n'existe même pas de
calendrier de réouverture et on peut le
comprendre les raisons sanitaires qui
font que c'est difficile là c'est la
mort économique qui les guette et
j'envoie ce petit message car l'étude
qui est cité c'est une étude que la
sacem avait fait pour le milieu de
l'électro c'est effectivement le poids
économique de ce secteur
les dj et compositeur électro sont
membres de notre maison c'est un secteur
qui rayonne à l'international et c'est
peut-être le dernier secteur qui serait
complètement des confiné big ben et si
j'aimerais entendre le créateur que vous
êtes avez vous quel est votre votre
sentiment est ce que vous vous dites
après tout c'est vrai qu'on a quand même
de la chance le l'état français a fait
beaucoup pour les artistes et puis on va
s'en contenter
pendant quelques mois où vous vous dites
non
le compte n'y est pas du tout les choses
ne sont pas faites comme il faut non je
jusqu'ici l'état français a pas mal de
choses permettre aux créateurs et aux
artistes de pouvoir tels que par exemple
les repentants en ce sens que si on peut
financer la prudence à la consommation
s'est orientée face à travers le
financement de la création en fait quoi
parce que sans création ya pas de
consommation pour que les gens nous
disent quand smoky et les objets qu'ils
soient faits des objets mathématiques
matérialiser matériel et des matériels
et qui ont besoin de francs il faut
financer les réacteurs et le financement
des créateurs allant par exemple de la
sacem qui est une maison qui grâce à
laquelle par exemple l'auteur
compositeur qui bénéficient du milieu et
la partie l'année prochaine il y aura
une nouvelle mutuelle qui m'accompagnait
et des artistes et les créateurs des
mailings ou des moins fortunés et je
sens que pour cela on a besoin de
financement qu'est ce qui a déjà été
fait je pense qu'on a vraiment besoin de
financement si on voudrait que demain ça
fait des récits des mâles qualité parce
que financer en fait des créateurs c'est
financer toute cette tension fait les
producteurs les festivals qui tourne
nous nous sommes le seul le maillon
central en fait de tout de la chaîne et
donc il est vraiment important que ce
matin si cette proximité finances est
passé à travers lui romain goupil qu'en
pensez vous sans créations pas de
relance nous dit blick bassy ce qui
semble assez juste et puis on n'a pas
parlé de l'europe aussi que fait
union européenne pour la culture alors
que pour le coup c'est la culture
mondiale qui souffre et notamment
européennes c'est une catastrophe donc
le gouvernement français essaye de faire
le maximum pour éviter cet effondrement
mais le préjudice que qui a en ce moment
par rapport à cette situation fait que
on en arrive
arrivé comme artiste ou c'est notre
boulot comme scénariste au conte de la
belle au bois dormant c'est à dire allez
un petit bisou et ça y est la crise est
finie mais là on voit que c'est en
accordéon ou que c'est en permanence ça
recommence que ça se déroule déclenché
dans un autre pays européen
donc ce problème de la création ce
problème de la culture est quelque chose
qu'il faut protéger par rapport à ce
qu'on voit aux états unis ces trois
millions de gens qui sont carrément sans
travail alors là les musiciens tous ceux
qui étaient dans les orchestres et des
licenciements en masse et une crise
économique qui est à l'image de la ville
de communes économique du pays
donc là effectivement on essaye ce que
ça s'effondre pas mais il ya eu c'est
une catastrophe pour tous ces mots pour
tous et le tir est pour tous ceux qui
ont envie de faire des choses et de de
participer à la création
jean noël tronc s'arrête on n'a pas
parlé de l'europe est elle au rendez
vous non je vais être direct je pense
que beaucoup de députés européens se
sont battus remarquablement pour
augmenter un peu les moyens dans le
budget de la commission pour la culture
enfin on parle d'une goutte d'eau à la
culture dans le budget de l'union
européenne aujourd'hui c'est un millième
par rapport aux fameux 1% culturelle qui
existe dans la plupart des états
d'europe
non la commission l'europe tous ensemble
on peut faire une chose c'est que le 9
décembre le commissaire breton et la
vice présidente verts stago doivent
présenter un plan d'action pour
numérique la chiche
voilà ça fait dix ans qu'on parle de
réguler le numérique les grandes
plateformes de streaming ne font
aujourd'hui l'objet d'aucune forme de
régulation
or que ce soit leurs algorithmes et ce
qu'ils en font un quentin spotify
annonce qui propose de payer moins cher
les artistes en les plaçant plus haut
dans ses playlists sait bien qui
reconnaît qu'il est en train de devenir
un vrai média où que ce soit la
diversité culturelle et la bravo au
cinéma qui a donné l'exemple 30%
d'oeuvre du visuel dans des plateformes
comme netflix ou disney plus c'est prévu
hees avait transposé grâce au parlement
français en france parmi les premiers
pays d'europe il est temps qu'on agisse
concrètement sur la régulation de ces
plateformes faute de quoi dans cinq ans
quand tu y aura éventuellement une
nouvelle crise on n'aura que ses yeux
pour pleurer parce qu'une bonne partie
de notre diversité culturelle aura tout
simplement disparu et on aura le
contrôle du marché européen de l'édition
et de la production à la diffusion à la
distribution entre les mains de cinq à
dix acteurs mondiaux dont
malheureusement peu seront européens
tu n'es pas rejetons série quand on
parlait de ce qu'avait fait l'état
français des nombreuses aides des
milliards débloqués mon la culture et
l'europe
c'est vrai que l'europe n'a pas accès la
dimension budgétaire sur la culture
c'est une réalité mais parce qu'il ya
des priorités comme la transition
énergétique également et puis les
industries donc moi je là aussi j'ai une
forme bien sûr de déception j'aimerais
que la culture soit beaucoup plus
présente dans la relance européenne même
si roselyne bachelot a obtenu pour la
france un très bel arbitrages sur la
part de la culture dans le plan de
relance français et on voit que ce n'est
pas toujours le cas dans les différents
plans nationaux même si à certains pays
qui prend les efforts mais je crois que
jean noël tronc a raison en europe
l'essentiel c'est quand même la
régulation et il est temps que l'europe
prenne à bras le corps le sujet de la
régulation vis-à-vis de ses plates
formes américaines il n'est pas possible
que les plateformes les géants du
numérique colonise notre imaginaire et
notre lien social comme elles sont en
train de le faire c'est à dire notamment
en exploitant massivement nos données et
en finalement
remplaçants notre imaginaire par un
autre et j'ai le sentiment là je vais
être positif quand même que la
commission a pris conscience de ce
phénomène et j'attends beaucoup des
directives les deux directives qui vont
être présentées mi décembre
même si il faut dire la vérité le chemin
sera long puisqu'il faudra le débattre
au parlement
il faudra les transposer au niveau
européen et donc il y a un an à un an et
demi de rudes batailles où tout le monde
doit peser les parlementaires français
les parlementaires européens les états
il faut qu'on soit tous au rendez vous
de ce rapport de force alors qu'amd et
qu'on finira t-on la culture c'est la
grande question le 15 décembre si et
seulement si on est en dessous des 5000
contamination par jour les théâtres les
cinémas les salles de spectacles
pourront rouvrir on a appris tout à
l'heure d'après nos confrères de
libération qu a priori ça pourrait être
compromis tout le monde retient son
souffle sur tous les artistes on en
écoute quelques uns c'est dans ce clip
de la sacem que vous avez pu voir
aujourd'hui sur cette journée spéciale
dont public sénat et partenaires
j'espère avec tout mon coeur que les
savants se ré ouvrir bientôt sans la
musique
j'ai qu'une envie c'est d'aller voir
beaucoup de compositeurs confine airs de
musiques de films j'ai une pensée
particulière pour toutes les personnes
qui gravitent autour d'un artiste y ce
métier continue à faire rêver autant
qu'il m'a fait rêver et dans cette
épreuve tout le monde a besoin de tout
le monde a très vite sur scène j'espère
et en attendant prenez son nom et vous
blick bassy qu'est-ce que vous souhaitez
le plus ardemment pour les pour les
jours à venir ne suivent sont fait avoir
au contraire le 17 décembre
je croise les doigts et de faire que à
partir desquels les choses vont repartir
peut-être doucement mais déjà le fait
aujourd'hui j'entends quelqu'un
programmateur de groupes estivale qui
commence à être animés d'une nouvelle
dynamique pour l'année prochaine
j'espère vraiment j'ai vraiment que
l'année prochaine on pourra repartir
julien bargeton vous avez des
informations c'est que les chiffres ne
sont pas bons on sait que le
gouvernement réfléchit à ne pas ouvrir
les salles de spectacles dès le 15
décembre comme c'était prévu dans le
processus de départ que savez vous de ça
je souhaite de tout mon coeur que les
salles puis serait ouvrir parce que nous
l'attendons maintenant tout cela nous le
savons depuis le début est soumis à des
conditions sanitaires
il ne faut pas que nos efforts
collectifs qui ont permis d'obtenir cet
allègement progressif du confinement
soit remise en cause
on voit malheureusement que l'épidémie
galope aux états unis en italie mais
également les signes de l'asie ne sont
pas très bons puisque la corée du sud et
le japon qui jusque là allait bien
malheureusement vive sort est en train
de vivre un nouveau pic de l'épidémie
donc je croise les doigts je suis comme
tout le monde je ne suis pas médecin et
je fais confiance aux autorités
sanitaires et aux autorités politiques
pour prendre les bonnes décisions mais
nous savons c'est conditionné au fait
que les efforts collectifs permettent
d'éviter que nous soyons obligés de
retarder cette sortie progressive du
confinement
jean noël tronc avoue redouter fortement
qu'on nous on ne rouvre pas les salles
de spectacles dès le 15 décembre comme
c'était prévu au départ
moi ce qui me frappe c'est l'avalanche
de vidéos j'ai reçu de nos sociétaires
là je viens de recevoir une dose de
fifres
d'akhenaton l'un des leader d'iam qui
prend la parole comme des dizaines
d'autres aujourd'hui pour dire un
message d'espoir mais aussi un message
d'inquiétude très profonde parce que on
ne sent pas pour être très claire les
choses pour le 15 décembre
on parle du 20 janvier comme je
l'expliquais tout à l'heure s'il n'y a
pas en janvier février au plus tard un
plan progressif de retour à la normale
les festivals de cet été sans compromis
est là pour parler d'un film qui m'a
beaucoup beaucoup touché qu'à mourir à
30 ans petit clin d'oeil on dit souvent
les droits d'auteur font vivre ce qui
nous font rêver
ce qu'il faudrait assurer c'est que ceux
qui nous font rêver puisse continuer à
vivre vivre de quoi de leur travail
la possibilité que des milliers je dis
bien des milliers d'auteurs dotrice de
compositeurs de compositrice de
réalisateurs de réalisatrice d'écrivains
de petites sociétés comme les éditeurs
de musique s'arrête arrêtent leur
carrière dans les mois qui viennent elle
est très sérieuse c'est pour ça que dans
l'immédiat le plus important c'est des
compensations sur ses pertes des prises
en charge de l'accompagnement le budget
du cnm demain le crédit d'impôt pour les
éditeurs et puis après un calendrier de
retour à la normale quand les conditions
sanitaires le permettront et le message
est passé merci infiniment à tous les
quatre d'avoir participé à ce débat
spécial fin de cette émission on se
retrouve demain à 18 heures et à 22h30
dans un instant auditions publiques
l'invité ce soir fabien roussel
secrétaire national du pcf et puis
demain vous retrouve évidemment bonjour
chez vous dès 7h30 au rayonnement de
chimie recevra adrien quoi tenant ce
numéro deux de la france insoumise je
vous souhaite une excellente soirée sur
public sénat
[Musique]